vamos a aplicar la ley de enfriamiento
de newton y solo para recordar
teníamos que si t mayúscula es la
temperatura y t minúscula era el tiempo
pero dado en minutos entonces teníamos
que la tasa de cambio o la derivada de
la temperatura respecto del tiempo era
proporcional verdad a la diferencia y de
hecho déjenme ponerlo así era menos una
constante por la diferencia de la
temperatura con la temperatura ambiente
del cuarto donde estuviéramos o donde
estuviera el objeto depositado verdad y
realmente este signo menos o este signo
es útil de tal suerte que cuando la
temperatura es más grande que la
temperatura ambiente entonces todo esto
tiene que irse enfriando es decir la
temperatura tiene que disminuir y por lo
tanto tiene que ser negativo verdad
entonces si te es mayor que te a este
término es positivo la k es positiva y
con el menos se hace negativo lo mismo
si tuviéramos que si la temperatura
fuera más chica que la temperatura
ambiente entonces ésta empieza a
elevarse verdad es decir el objeto
empieza a calentarse y entonces si esto
si te es menor que te a este término es
negativo con este menos se vuelve
positivo y entonces la temperatura crece
verdad entonces parece para este vídeo
solo vamos a tomar el caso en el que la
temperatura es mayor o igual que tea
vamos a pensar que a lo mejor tenemos no
sé un tazón con avena caliente
verdad y por estar muy caliente es decir
estar por arriba de la temperatura
ambiente entonces
va a ser
bueno en realidad solo vamos a
considerar ese caso verdad y de hecho
vimos las soluciones generales en el
vídeo anterior a esta ecuación
diferencial pero bueno aquí vamos a
considerar que nuestro tazón de avena es
que tiene una temperatura que está por
arriba de la temperatura ambiente y
vimos que la solución general era la
temperatura verdad como función del
tiempo era una constante por la
exponencial verdad el exponencial de
menos k t ok más la temperatura ambiente
más la temperatura ambiente ok entonces
vamos ahora a dar una solución
particular vamos a dar una solución
particular vamos a suponer que la
temperatura ambiente digamos que tenemos
un cuarto muy grande y tenemos nuestro
tazón de avena y digamos que ese cuarto
donde se encuentra el tazón está 20
grados centígrados muy bien perdón en 20
grados celsius quise decir entonces si
si el cuarto está 20 grados celsius y
ponemos digamos que la temperatura
inicial de nuestro tazón de avena es de
80 grados celsius ok entonces realmente
está muy caliente y vamos a poner una
condición más digamos que después de dos
minutos
después de dos minutos tendremos el
tazón de avena
a 60 grados celsius muy bien entonces
usando la ley de newton o la ley de
enfriamiento de newton y esta
información inicial
buscaremos cuál es la solución
particular a este problema es decir cómo
expresar la temperatura en función del
tiempo ok y además vamos a tratar de
responder la siguiente pregunta cuántos
minutos verdad cuántos minutos debe
estarse enfriando nuestro tazón de avena
para poder alcanzar los 40 grados
celsius entonces cuántos minutos debe
enfriarse para
para llegar a 40 grados celsius muy bien
entonces como siempre te invito a que
hagas una pausa y pienses cómo resolver
este problema
entonces suponiendo que ya hiciste una
pausa vamos a vamos a proceder a
resolverlo entonces vamos a usar la
información que tenemos acá arriba para
determinar las constantes de ica muy
bien entonces él siempre lo más fácil es
considerarla la condición inicial es
decir si tenemos una temperatura inicial
de 80 grados y ya bueno ya no voy a
poner grados perdón grados celsius ok
entonces por un lado esto es t evaluado
en 0 verdad pero por el otro se veía a
sustituir aquí con con cero verdad
entonces era la menos acá por cero es
era la menos 0 a la 0 es 1 y entonces
del lado derecho sólo tenemos c más la
temperatura ambiente pero la temperatura
ambiente dijimos que era de 20 grados
celsius entonces aquí simplemente vamos
a agregar 20 verdad y entonces podemos
calcular fácilmente quién es la cee
porque si restamos 20 de ambos lados si
restamos 20 de ambos lados
tendremos que la constante se vale 60
verdad la constante veces vale 60 ahora
vamos a tratar de encontrar cuánto vale
nuestra constante acá verdad es lo que
sigue y entonces podemos utilizar esta
información cuál es la temperatura
después de dos minutos entonces la
temperatura después de dos minutos son
60 verdad por un lado y por el otro lado
es sede de hecho creo que valdría la
pena de escribir quien es nuestra
función ahora verdad tdt es ese que en
este caso es 60 por el elevado a la
menos k
cate más la temperatura ambiente que son
20 verdad entonces por un lado sabemos
que la temperatura después de dos
minutos son 60 grados verdad y por otro
lado tendríamos que evaluar con t
igualados verdad entonces sería 60 por
el elevado a la menos
al menos dos cadáver that sería poner de
igualados entonces tenemos menos 2 k más
20 más 2020 muy bien y entonces todo lo
que tenemos que hacer ahora es tratar de
despejar quienes acá muy bien entonces
podemos restar 20 de ambos lados y lo
que obtenemos es que 40 es igual a 60 y
60 y elevado a la menos 2 k muy bien
ahora dividimos de ambos lados entre 60
verdad y tenemos del lado izquierdo 40
en 360 eso son dos tercios
y esto será igual ha elevado a la menos
2 k elevado a la menos 2 k entonces para
poder quitar este exponencial tenemos
que obtener un logaritmo natural de
ambos lados verdad entonces tenemos el
logaritmo natural dejen de hacerlo igual
con con verde verdad porque se relaciona
con la exponencial entonces el logaritmo
natural de dos tercios debe ser igual a
menos 2 cabras del logaritmo natural
digamos que anula la expone o más bien
cancela el exponencial de verdad y ahora
simplemente dividimos entre menos 2
verdad entonces obtenemos que cada k es
igual al logaritmo natural
y bueno vamos a poner primero menos son
medio menos un medio de pasar este menos
dos dividiendo verdad menos un medio del
logaritmo natural de dos tercios
tercios y entonces aquí tenemos nuestro
valor de acá que es un número bastante
raro verdad entonces de hecho podemos
observar aquí que acá es un número
positivo porque el logaritmo natural de
dos tercios es negativo ya que dos
tercios es más chico que uno verdad y
con este menos pues se vuelve algo
positivo entonces realmente la fórmula a
la que llegamos es la siguiente es tdt
tdt es igual a 60 60 por el elevado a la
menos k
- acá que en este caso pues este menos
con este menos se cancelan y nos queda
un medio del logaritmo natural de dos
tercios 2
al revés serían dos tercios que
multiplica a t verdad ahí lo tenemos más
20 más 20 y quizás ya no voy a seguir
usando tantos colores verdad entonces
este exponente podemos ver que es
negativo entonces todo va bien ok
entonces todo todo marcha en orden ahora
realmente tenemos que responder esta
pregunta cuántos minutos deben pasar
para que nuestra votación de avena pueda
enfriarse hasta llegar a 40 grados
centígrados verdad entonces ya no voy a
usar tantos colores simplemente vamos a
hacerlo directamente nosotros queremos
40 grados centígrados por un lado
40 grados centígrados verdad y esto debe
ser igual a 60 por el ala un medio
logaritmo natural de dos tercios por t
que es justamente la que queremos
encontrar más 20 verdad entonces si
pasamos 20 restando
sí entonces pasando 20 restando tenemos
aquí 20 igual a 60 a la un medio
logaritmo natural de dos tercios que
multiplica de verdad y luego dividimos
entre 60 y que es lo que nos queda 20
entre 60 es un tercio y esto es igual a
e al a un medio logaritmo natural de dos
tercios de doradas y luego podemos sacar
un logaritmo natural verdad para quitar
la exponencial entonces tenemos
logaritmo natural de un tercio debe ser
igual a un medio logaritmo natural de
dos tercios que multiplica t y entonces
ya podemos despejar la t t sería
puede pasar multiplicando dos veces el
logaritmo natural de un tercio dividido
entre el logaritmo natural de dos
tercios y entonces solo para darnos una
idea de cuánto tiempo tiene que ocurrir
vamos a calcularlo
y para eso voy a utilizar la calculadora
que tiene google en su página entonces
vamos a poner aquí 22 que multiplica el
logaritmo natural de un tercio un tercio
verdadera lo que teníamos dividido entre
el logaritmo natural de dos tercios
nos da esto y entonces según la
calculadora son 5.42 aproximadamente
entonces esto es más o menos 5.42
minutos verdad el tiempo estaba dado en
minutos entonces después de 5.42 minutos
vamos a tener que nuestro tazón de avena
se encuentra a 40 grados centígrados